On the more philosophical level, when delta debugging returns, is not only to simply itself
but is also to cause for the failure.
What is the cause anyway?
Assume i have a window and here comes a ball flying to the window and the window breaks.
You would think later that the ball is the cause for the window to break.
But why is it the cause? This is so called counterfactual definition of causality
which is the most used in our context. It works as follows:
We have two events, and A comes before B.
Say A, is the ball flying towards the window? and B, is the window shattering?
We now say that A causes B, if B had not occurred if A had not occurred.
Applied to our example, we can say that the ball causes the window to shatter
if the window had not shatter if the ball has not arrived which actually is true.
With the ball, the window shatters. Without the ball, the window does not shatter.
And since the ball precede the shattering, everything is in place to say
that the ball caused the window to shatter.
If this sounds complicated, we haven't seen much.
Causality is one of the most disputed subject in Philosophy.
Some philosophers are even saying that causality does not really exist. It's just an illusion.
For our purposes; however, that is within debugging,
this counterfactual definition does a good job.
First, we have the ball then we have the window crashing forward.
First, we have the defect and then we have the failure.
So why does delta debugging returned cause?
Simply because there might be a large set of events that all could or could not contribute to the failure.
The sun is shining. The clouds are in the sky. There's a nice tree along.
And what areas that none of this is relevant for shattering the window.
Only the ball by simplifying the scenery towards a single element
that is responsible for the test to fail, delta debugging returns the cause.